enemy presence
let's roll
[Music]
oh
adios
moving out we're ready to go but easy's
off getting us some intel from a guy in
kuya can you make sure she gets to the
outpost safely can't wait to meet her
hey nico good chance to test our new
pilots no
sure
you wanna go
on my way
there she is
nice to meet you
buenas hardware
no chopper
figured you'd bring one
oh i think i know where to get one
see dropping supplies now
sorrento i'd say the pilots are gonna
work out fine
let's go easy
ride with you
mira where are we going
listo just got here sending you
coordinates
nice city
or city always been that way
before he moved to his castle in the sky
espinoza headquarters was in hueva
all the money is there
so
people in kuya get by other ways like
selling black market information to the
army of chaos
what's the internet
mira's eyes only
turn on the radio need music
what are they doing that they need to
hide their identities probably just
something they got used to do when they
were overseas they didn't want to have
their looks like these spots they were
doing all that good work
sort of like giving to charity
anonymously
yeah i i just think
how things are now seeing a black hand
in solice used to be a thing of comfort
for a lot of people when i used to be on
patrol the people i met actually knew my
name and knew that i was there to help
them
now thanks for the lift hardware
wow santiago anytime
we're here
i'm in the control center
we're pushing forward but none of that
matters unless we can disable yappa's
defenses
ec and i have been working on that
all of these facilities house prototype
weather course and each core is
connected to yappa's defense network
it starts with artillery see
if we can plant a piracy in those
weather course we can send a message up
the network causing malfunctions in the
tower's machinery everything breaks boom
no more artillery
then we just have to blizzard
one thing at a time mira
tell me more about these facilities
housing the weather course
this is protected by a sandstorm mirror
here
gracias easy
what's that
information on a place called la masmura
is a prison hidden in the desert
something gabriela said
i think my uncle lanza might still be
alive
and if he is he's being held there
and uh he can help us get into zoro
he helped your father build project
yappa
peter if he's still alive i'll find him
here
he's on a trace
according to easy it's not on the
network but i have an old friend cesar
he has a theory that might help us
then let's hear what he has to say
and this is
we don't know much about that
are you ever going to answer this i'm
not an agency man anymore
rico
those coordinates are close look
nice
that can't be a coincidence
i'll check it out
i'm sending you all the data you'll need
to your ar lens
good
let's start hitting oscar when it hurts
you